no I think I think Facebook is going to
be fine Facebook has a long history of
planning a change in the service that's
that's good for them in some way or
other overstepping their baths
apologizing and scaling back but not
scaling back to the point where they
were before the change in a way facebook
now uses the overstep apology reaction
pattern as a way of seeing how far they
can go at any given at any given
cultural moment the other thing I think
about Facebook is that Facebook is in a
way our current our current target for
worries about privacy in exactly the
same way the music industry obsessed
about Napster or newspapers obsessed
about craigslist which is to say the
logic of Facebook the logic that
Facebook is exposing is in many ways
logic that's implicit in the Internet
itself Facebook just happens to be its
current corporate avatar but if
craigslist had died out in 2005 it
wouldn't have helped the classified ad
business much because somebody else
would have figured it out and done it so
it seems to me that a lot of the lot of
the trouble that Facebook is in right
now is really people grappling with what
the internet means for privacy rather
than Facebook what I what I do think is
that Facebook is probably close to the
outer limit of what it can get away with
in terms of privacy I wish as many
people do that they were a better actor
on the subject of privacy's and they've
been but their business models pretty
clearly maximizing sharing maximizing
disclosure maximizing number of Facebook
URLs in circulation on the open Internet
I think that they will have to fight
harder to get out from under the
problems they've currently created but I
don't think any significant challenger
to Facebook is going to arise in the
next couple of years and however much
bowing and scraping they have to do now
including possibly before a
congressional committee I don't believe
it's
going to clip their business much in the
long term